we were able to already answer some
interesting questions about the
different plans at the super yoga studio
using the equations we set up but I'm a
very visual guy and I want to make sure
that I analyze the problem fully before
I spend my hard-earned dollars and what
I want to do now is really see a visual
representation for the relationship
between how many sessions I attend and
how much it's going to cost me and I'm
gonna do it for the trial plan and the
basic plan and to do that down here on
the horizontal axis I'm gonna plot the
number of sessions that I attend so s
that's is equal to the number of
sessions I attend per month and then
here in the vertical axis I'm going to
plot I'm gonna plot how much it's going
to cost me depending on how many
sessions I attended so let's think about
these points right over here and then
even also think about how this equation
relates to what we might end up drawing
so the first point here is that if I if
I spend if I go to no sessions it's
gonna cost me $0 so where would I plot
that right over here well if I attend no
sessions and I should have marked off a
zero right over here it's gonna cost me
$0 so it's this point just like that now
let's think about if I attend one
session if I has ten to one session
it'll be $12 where would I plot that
well one session it's gonna cost to me
$12 you see this is $15 so twelve
dollars gonna be right around there so
I'll put it right over there and then if
I attend two sessions where would I plot
that well two sessions are gonna cost me
twenty four dollars so we get right
right about there and then what about
three sessions and I could keep going
four or five six on and on and on but
let's just try three I think you'll
you'll get the general idea
three sessions cost $36 three sessions
cost $36 and you see that all of these
points seem to sit on a line and I can
attempt I'll attempt my best to draw
that line and this line essentially
describes all of the possible
combinations of cost for a given number
of sessions so any point here especially
if we are assuming that we allow
fractional sessions that's not
convention practice conventional
practice for most yoga studios but this
one is the super yoga studio so it
allows you to attend four and a half
sessions or one and a half sessions or
exactly half a session so if you attend
half a session it's going to cost you $6
another way to think about it is if you
attend 2-0 sessions it'll be zero
dollars but then as you add a session as
you add a session so you go to the right
one step it's gonna cost you $12 more so
then you're going to go up you're going
to go up twelve dollars so we went to
the right one we went up twelve if we go
to the right one again we're gonna go up
twelve again because every session we
add is gonna cost us twelve extra
dollars we go from zero to twelve to
twenty four if you add another session
you go up twelve you go up twelve again
if you take away the session you'll go
down twelve and so it's a kind of a way
of thinking about how steep this line is
every time you go one of the right
you're going 12 up now let's think about
the same thing for the basic plan how we
might actually plot that so I'll start
I'll start with this point right over
here and the basic plan what I spent is
when I go to zero sessions it cost me
twenty dollars where would I plot that
on my graph so zero sessions are going
to cost me twenty dollars that's that
point right over there
what about one session well one session
is gonna cost me twenty eight dollars
one session is going to cost me twenty
eight dollars and another way to think
about it you pay twenty no matter what
and as you add one session your total
cost went up by eight you added one
session your total cost went up by eight
this scale and this scale is not the
same if I did it as scale then you would
see these lines would look a lot steeper
and I would have to make this axis go a
lot lot taller but hopefully you get the
idea you add one session we went up by
eight you add another session so that
was 128 that's that point right over
there so if you have two sessions gonna
cost us thirty-six dollars two sessions
well where would we plot that two
sessions are going to cost $36
that is right over there or another way
to think of it think of it we were at 28
we added another session so we're gonna
add $8 to our cost so 28 plus 8 gets us
to $36 now let's do this other point
once again we can keep going
where would we plot the three sessions
so if we attend three sessions it's
gonna cost us forty-four dollars so
that's right right about there right
about there and once again we added a
session and we added eight dollars to
our cost and you see these two these two
seem to sit on a line these two seem to
although I didn't draw it as well as I
can so these two seem seem to sit on a
line now this by itself is interesting
but what might be even more interesting
is where these two lines intersect we
see that they have different steepness
--is so at some point they should
intersect and what's exciting about well
I shall let you think about what is
exciting about where these two lines
intersect what does it tell us about the
sessions and the costs at those points
and I'll leave you there and we'll
explore this more in the next video